she came behind me with a charger cord
foone charger cord and wrapped it around
my
throat I was trying to like choke me
with B but I had used and like kind of
pushed her back okay just weeks after
giving birth this Georgia mother was
gunned down in her own home by a woman
claiming to be a friend she met online
in a mommy group instead the suspect
kidnapped her six- week old twin boys
and made a break for it she kept saying
I'm taking the boys I'm taking the boys
body camera video captures it all from
the initial emergency response where she
shot where shot two witness statements
and when I came out she was right there
she's like I got shot I got shot I got
shot they took my kids they took my kids
she was and even the family's reaction
to the news what happened to
her shot what do you mean she was
shot all this before First Responders
rescue the babies hours after their
abduction what happened to
her shut what do you mean she was
shut while the incident happened on May
11th 2021 body camera video was only
recently made public it shows Savannah
Georgia police respond to the scene
where 23-year-old Gabrielle Rogers had
been shot three times where she
shot
Witnesses on the scene describe what
happened including the woman who first
called 911 I was in the house and
somebody bang they didn't ring the
doorbell at first they just started
banging like something like the police
but and I'm like and I'm trying to get
to the door cuz I'm way down in the den
with my young and by that time I guess
she figured to hit the doorbell so she
actually hit the doorbell and when I
came out she was right there she was
like I got shot I got shot I got shot
they took my kids they took my kids she
was just paying again and so she sat
down on my bench for a few minutes then
she laid back and then she got up again
and she kept saying Catherine Catherine
and I said you know cuz I she I called
911 while I was talking to her she said
call 911 I been shot I said where you
been shot cuz I didn't see it at first
she goes in my ear and you can see her
ear was like whatever and uh so I kept
talking to her trying to keep her keep
her Cent because I know I don't want her
to pass out on me well obvious she did
pass out before you guys got here so I
don't know anything I never heard no
shots I I she just came to my door cuz I
guess she don't have a phone over the
witness
think one in the head one in the chest
and then one in the leg so and then she
walked over this way she ran the blood
the the scenes inside that house it
looks like it happened right in the
front living room uhhuh the um the car
seat is sitting right there there's
blood kind of like all around the car
seat she said that she has kids inside
and she just h heard banging and
hollering at the door she came out she
was collapsed in front and the kids are
gone miraculously Rogers is able to
communicate with First Responders
despite her multiple gunshot wounds the
suspect suspect is a Kathleen Daniels
black female this is straight from the
victim she's talking Kathleen Daniels
she's black female and works at Memorial
Hospital came here supposedly she met
her in a mama's mommy's group and she
was bringing her
formula and then next thing she know
this is what a friend over there said
that she was meeting this lady up from
uh a m mommy's group bringing her
formula next thing she knows she came um
home the friend came here and there's
blood everywhere and uh but it's coming
from the victim Kathleen Daniels black
female Works about Moria hospital she's
the one that shot her and took the kids
she lives in po did you get all that but
she don't know what vehicle she was
driving she didn't see Rogers tells
First Responders she met the suspect
Kathleen Daniels on a mommy's group
online soon investigators begin the
search for the boys six week old Matteo
and Lorenzo what do we care about well
the victim finding the children correct
the victim is here is being treated we
care about finding the kids all right
well let's go then I got a photo see if
we can he with they're at EMS they're I
guess they went to Memorial meanwhile
Rogers is loaded into an ambulance
before she's rushed to the hospital I
have a trauma protocol
in we are currently ounded a 23y old
female she's got one hole to the right
Temple patient is conscious alert and
answers questions appropriately GCS 15
um actually GCS of 13 um she's got one
hole to the left or the right Temple
she's got one to left
breast
um just inferior and lateral to the um
nipple and she's got one to upper thigh
right thigh she's probably only about
maybe 4 in from the crease of the leg
patient is answering questions um I have
a date of birth I don't have a whole lot
of information a tourni kit was applied
to the right leg priority EMS arrival
current heart rate is 117 she shows
signus on the monitor O2 sat 97 she is
on 15 L um nonre breather and she's got
a BP of 125 over 882 I did get an 18 in
the right arm um we tried a 16 that
blue we're probably only about 4 minutes
out still on the scene rogers's sister
begins crying hysterically before
telling another family member she's been
shocked we know who did
this where did they
leave a female took the kids hey my man
you got to get on the other side of the
T tell me tell you in a second calm down
talk to you let us talk to you first
calm down
brother what happened to
her shot what do you mean she was
shot let her exp she got to explain it
to you
man hey look can I get
it
soon investigators realize the name
Kathleen Daniels is actually an alias
and they're really searching for Angela
Montgomery when police arrive at
Montgomery's home they meet up with her
mother who tells them the babies are
Angela's youall know whose babies those
were my daughter who's your what's your
daughter's name Angela those are
Angela's babies are you sure yeah you
sure Angela didn't lose her
babies she she never told
you but you think those are Angela's
babies that's what she said is that the
first time you've seen those babies yes
it's at the Montgomery home where
Savannah police finally rescued the twin
boys several hours after they were
kidnapped put them in the
car oh you got the
baby back seat front
seat okay you are absolutely good get
mark up that intersection and walk off
car your
thing bab hey babies all
right all right hey
darling hey darling somebody we have
both babies I all one somebody advise if
we have both we have both we have both
[Applause]
got
a yeah yeah this one's still
[Music]
sleeping through here we get hi baby I'm
very happy to see you hi you were
worried about all right Slow Down slow
down while in the hospital Rogers is
able to identify Montgomery as the
[Music]
suspect ready for the next
photo H who's
that you recognize her who's
that say it again Kathleen the same day
Montgomery is questioned by police she
explained she had a miscarriage and
planned to break the news to her fiance
that morning I woke up this morning okay
with plans to tell my fiance that I'm
not like that I miscarried okay who's
your fiance Dale Foster do I have to say
the names I'm sorry no no we just we
just same people okay yeah um that's
when my day started but soon her story
goes off the rails as Montgomery
mentions her fraternal twin sister
Destiny she implies Destiny may be
responsible for the shooting I swear on
everything I love I got a call you can
check my phone if you have it it was
from Destiny and I from who her name's
Destiny Destiny her name on her driver's
license reads Destiny Scott
2598 she's a New York driver service
license and I don't know the numbers
okay I got a call telling me to come to
Gabby's address and I did okay by the
time I showed up there uh I promise I
just drove off I didn't even my like I
was driving my sedan this morning m i
saw everything that was on the thing and
I knew for a fact I'm not opposed to I
Knew whose kids came into the house the
first time I ever saw those kids this
morning was at the St Joseph's mhm
that's where I saw
them now did my gut tell me that it was
Gabby's kid and Gabby probably didn't
just let this
goh
maybe Honestly Gabby was friendly sorry
I don't know what I thought but I didn't
ask any questions and I said what do you
want me to do days later in
investigators get a clearer picture of
the attack when Rogers herself explains
what led up to the shooting she came
behind me with a charger cord foam
charger cord and wrapped it around my
throat it was trying to like choke me
with it but I had used my hands and like
kind of pushed her back
okay and like got out from under
it and then I was running and I heard a
pop M I was trying to get to the
boys but the door was closed and I was
like I need to go get help mhm and then
I heard another
pop and I
fell and then I got
up ran to the neighbors banged on their
door they didn't answer so I remember
running across the street
Falling knocking on that door
okay and then that's really all I can
really remember she just kept
saying how she was upset because she
couldn't find her phone mhm and then she
kept
saying I'm taking the boys I'm taking
the boys and I was like what no you're
not you're taking my kids mhm she was
like they're not yours and I was like
they M like I just was so confused and
this was before or after the Char like
during her trying to choke me with the
charger
C you're doing great you're doing you're
doing fantastic this is an uncomfortable
memory and I just was trying to get
somebody to help like I didn't even know
she had shot me like I was just running
to get H
okay okay and then I
remember falling onto the neighbor's
doorstep and then thing I know I see my
sister running out of the house and I'm
like the boys she took my boys Rogers
even explained she'd been friends with
Montgomery for months ahead of the
shooting we've been talking for a couple
months we've actually had a couple
meetups MH which baffled me that this
even happened
because I never saw the signs like you
know we even went to the park and had a
picnic with her and her baby that was
the Thursday before the attack mhm but
she's been in the house a couple before
that yeah she's come over she dropped
some stuff off for me when I was
pregnant with the boy still in the
hospital hospital she came and brought
some stuff to the hospital for
me she's just been a really good
support and it just I just was so
confused on what was going on in the end
First Responders praise Rogers for her
ability to react and protect her sons
that's some serious Mama Bear energy um
for you to be able to run cuz you first
you ran over to the neighbors next to
you in the brick house house and then
you ran across the street uh
1314 um 12:14 right across the street
you were able to now you've been shot
three times and you're able to tell
them not basically what you told them
what happened and then you were able to
tell your sister and then your sister
was able to tell us because of that we
could un figure it out and so that was
remarkable why my boys are safe I just
wanted to make sure they were okay okay
the end they are last month Montgomery
pleaded guilty to charges of aggravated
assault and kidnapping her attorney also
noted She's suffering from mental
illness in all she was sentenced to 70
years reporting for long crime Network
I'm s Gillespie